and the FED yes or no I would like to
but that requires
legislation I make promises that I will
keep as your next president and here's
the promise I'll keep with respect to
the FED is a 90% headcount reduction at
the US fed combined with restoring
effectively a single mandate one purpose
Peg the dollar two Commodities stabilize
the dollar as a unit of measurement it
should be just a basic function of
arithmetic and nothing more and again
part of the problem is you got those not
23,000 people or so at the US Federal
Reserve now that we don't need to do
that narrow function of pegging the
dollar to Commodities they find things
to do that's where the Central Bank
digital currency comes from that's where
a lot of these the cbdc which is a backd
door way of ensuring a government
surveillance system of being able to
wipe you out for doing something the
government didn't approve of that's how
you get to riging money from on high
like Mana from heaven in the aim of
balancing inflation and unemployment
it's like the equivalent hitting two
Targets with one arrow and missing it
both